i've read in interviews that you talk
about how you're very shy
and for such a terrific actor you get
shy sometimes when the attention is on
you for example you hate it when people
sing happy birthday to you yeah i do
yeah i actually relate to that i i don't
love
i don't i don't love it either yeah i
don't love it either i don't like
praise for something that i didn't have
anything to do with
that's not a joke i really do feel like
people are happy
and what are you supposed to just stand
there and go yes i survived
so you you you hate it when people give
you that kind of attention
yeah like when you wrap a film there
they announce it and everyone starts
clapping and i always
i hate it i always get turned bright red
and i just get really embarrassed
because they don't do it for everyone
they don't do it for the crew they don't
so i just always feel like really weird
about it right because they're singling
you out in a way yeah they should sing
happy birthday to the parents
to my parents yes because they're the
ones that actually did something
exactly
um you're very shy but you
were you tried bartending for a while
and and you seemed like
to be a bartender you you need to really
be able to deal with a lot of strangers
and how could you have done that i don't
know
one of my friends was going to the
school and so i it sounded like fun
yeah and so i went and then i got my
little bartending license
and then i got a job and i didn't
realize that
like you know people always want the
bartender to drink with them
and i can have like two drinks and then
i'm just blacked out
right and so i was like you know and i'm
again i'm very shy so it was i was just
drunk and it was just bad
so you were just passed out behind the
bar yeah maybe 45 minutes into your
phone i don't even really remember
i was shocked because when i first uh
saw you it was in the girl with the
dragon tattoo and you were so good in
that
that i was convinced because your
character's swedish i was convinced that
you're a swedish
actress i get that sometimes and then i
found out that you're not
and i i couldn't believe it because you
really sold me on that idea that you're
swedish
do you believe it now i still believe it
i think you're swedish and you're
fooling me right now
i also believe by watching that movie
you kick so much ass in that movie
that you're an amazing fighter they must
have they must have taught you a lot of
cool stuff for that movie
i did i did a lot of kickboxing um and
some
jiu-jitsu right but i i forgot all the
jiu jitsu
i can't do any of that anymore you mean
you forgot it like i would learn a move
like that would like put you out in five
seconds
you put me out really yeah like a move
that could like put anyone out and then
i would get home and i would have
already forgotten it so
for some reason i couldn't retain the
jiu jitsu you probably shouldn't tell
people that you should just
let people see the movie and think
you're just this incredible badass so i
can still hurt someone
just not with jiu-jitsu okay when was
the last time that you've actually used
it in real life have you used it at all
in real life your moves
um not really at my best friend's
wedding this
uh one of her wait a minute i thought
you were going to say i was walking down
an
alley and you're like yeah oh yeah i
used it at my best friend's
wedding i killed the priest um
it was her her her now her husband her
his friend was very drunk and he was
like trying to get me to dance
which is basically like being in an
alley for me and having someone steal my
purse
yeah he was like trying to get me a
dance and he picked me up oh and i
didn't we just finished shooting i
really i don't know how it happened but
i just like put my hands on his throat
i don't know how it happened i just woke
up and the police were asking a lot of
questions
um you know now in the books a girl in
the dragon tattoo is based on the books
by steve larsen
and in those books your character
elizabeth is a redhead but you guys
didn't go that way
in the movie so much well no she's a
redhead but she dyes her hair black
right yes which is yeah was very
important to me because i
was a follower of the books you want to
be true to the books yes
but obviously there's no way to really
depict that in a movie except that um
i had to wear merkin do you know what a
merkin is
andy knows i know what american is one
of uh
oh yeah i do know what american is
american is kind of a
wig for for down below yes it's a
it's a wig for your lady bits
this interview's over
uh so you wore one of those for that
movie
yeah i mean they didn't they didn't ask
me to but i'm naked so much in it i
wanted one because it felt like a little
fur bikini
but i
feeling like such a perv now
tell me more about the fur bikini
uh my god really cute it was a cute
little for bikini and i had them make it
strawberry blonde
oh okay uh
no is that something that you you give
that back when you're done or do you
no i have it you have it okay okay
that's good you want to keep that
a lot of creeps on ebay